if you wear glasses you know wearing a
mask can be pretty annoying
the lenses will fog up the straps behind
your ears kind of become uncomfortable
well now some people are turning to
surgery during the pandemic for a fix
[Applause]
a relatively new form of eye surgery for
people who want to stop wearing glasses
or contacts
is gaining popularity in maryland during
the pandemic
it's called smile laser eye surgery and
smile is short for a small incision
lenticular extraction
dr sonny goal says smile is an
alternative to lasik
it was approved by the fda in 2016.
think of it as like small incision lasik
we're able to treat a patient without
making a large corneal flap
just making a very small four millimeter
incision up under the upper eyelid
glasses um especially with masks now
um fogging up constantly and just
so uncomfortable um on the back of the
ears with the mask and stuff
and so i just thought i've been thinking
about this for so
long it's time to just do it melissa
nelson recently had the surgery which
doctors say is less invasive and
patients recover faster
by the next day i was able to drive
wear eye makeup rub my eyes like other
eye surgery there is a risk of
complications
that includes glare and halos
particularly at night
also debris where the corneal disc was
removed inflammation and infection is
all possible
but despite the risks dr gold says his
patients have been very happy with the
surgery's results
this has just been a game changer for
them i mean they've been really
impressed by how quick and easy the
procedure is
research has shown that smile also
results in less dry eye symptoms than
lasik